and did you authorize evacuating animals
out of kabul over no that is absolutely
this whole thing is is is total rhubarb
uh i i
was very proud of what uh our armed
services did uh without pitting and it
was an amazing thing to to move 15 000
people out of kabul in the way that we
did uh i thought it was also
additionally uh very good that we were
able to help uh those vets
uh who who came out uh as well but the
uh i can tell you that the the military
you didn't intervene you didn't so the
military always always the military
always prioritized uh human uh beings
and that was quite right and i think we
should be incredibly proud of
what pity and what it achieved
uh well let's go straight to our
political correspondent uh kate mccann
and uh we heard uh there kate uh the
prime minister saying that they'd always
put uh people above uh animals but
that's not uh what's coming out of an
email uh that sky news has seen is it
well you said the military have always
prioritized people over animals and i
think the actual question here is
whether the prime minister and his
office intervened in a process that
would have allowed
a team a charity team which did include
animals but also as the prime minister
indicated there included vets and other
animal charity workers to leave that
country where others including charities
who were desperately trying to charter
their own planes to leave the country
were unable to do so the prime minister
called suggestions that he'd had any
intervention in that process total
rhubarb but
i think there is a question about
exactly what did happen here because
what we have is an mp trudy harrison who
is the personal secretary parliamentary
private secretary to the prime minister
so a close aide of boris johnson
involved pretty closely in efforts to
try and charter a plane to try and
ensure that these nasa charity animals
and some of the team were able to leave
the country and in the process of doing
that she made very clear to a number of
companies including one private charter
company that she did work with the prime
minister and she said that her boss was
very keen to see that happen now in
emails that we've seen this morning
these are uh involving involving virgin
atlantic obviously a huge international
airline
these are a series of emails that were
sent on the 23rd and 24th of august and
the first one of those is from a pilot
at the company to a senior manager at
virgin atlantic and it reads my local mp
trudy harrison is pps parliamentary
private secretary to the prime minister
and has sought my advice this evening on
the mechanics of transportation of a mr
farving and his afghan-based rescue dogs
and cats plus other evacuees from kabul
imminently she said relevant permissions
would be fast-tracked in government now
that there that line fast-tracked in
government is absolutely key because it
seems to indicate that trudy harrison
had suggested to the airline that she
was able to ensure that if a plane was
arranged it could get in and out of that
country at a time remember when lots of
people were trying to do the same and
failing that she would be able to pull
that off now a second email which is
from the pilot to the chief executive of
virgin atlantic sent the next day on the
24th of august reads my local mp trudy
harrison in brackets who is boris
johnson's pps and works at number 10 has
inquired of me yesterday evening whether
we can provide transportation for mr
penfarthing and his rescue animals and
others from kabul
she has said the transportation
secretary will provide whatever
assistance is required this being a
government-backed situation and clearly
incredibly sensitive i trust it's in
order to bring it to your attention in
case you wish to deal with it personally
yourself now again two things strike us
in that email conversation
between staff at virgin that miss
harrison had reportedly said the
transport secretary would provide
whatever assistance is required and also
that this situation was
government-backed now that is their
perception of her approach to virgin but
i think what's really important here is
this is towards the tail end of that
evacuation effort there were some very
bad headlines at the time suggesting
that the prime minister and his team
were not doing enough to help these
animals leave the country and there was
really a lot of pressure on government
ministers on the military on the defense
secretary to ensure that everybody who
had the right to leave that country
could do so at that time there was a lot
of pressure you can see those scenes
there very very desperate scenes lots of
women and children people absolutely
desperate to leave so
clearly a lot of pressure but the
suggestion from you know officials in
government a foreign office email for
example also suggested that the prime
minister had personally intervened was
that there was something going on here
behind the scenes now it's important to
say you heard it from boris johnson
there called it total rhubarb the number
10 have said that this is not the case
although this morning they did not deny
that conversations had taken place
between the prime minister and judy
harrison on this subject miss harrison
herself has given a statement to sky
news she says i was assisting penn
farthing and now zad as a constituency
mp in response to many copeland
constituents requests to assist i was
contacted directly by over 40
constituents last summer asking for my
support for the charity staff and
animals as part of my efforts to help
them i reached out to a pilot in my
constituency for some advice
now there are those who say that none of
our constituents were actually directly
involved in the evacuation they question
her involvement as a constituency mp and
i say again you know the question the
statements that were issued during those
email conversations that seemed to
suggest that trudy harrison had the
backing of the government clearly you
have both her response and number 10s to
those claims